I was at VidCon now I'm at leakycon this
is London back there I want a fire
escape that's pretty cool next week I'll
be at summer in the city three guns
three weeks ah we'll see how I feel
after that London has been treating me
nicely aside from a little bit of jet
lag also recording an entire vlog with
the sound being really messed up so it
sounds like this Wow what did I just
walk through I found it I found a spinny
table I know that the vast majority of
people who want to go to VidCon can't go
to VidCon so I don't want to talk about
how great VidCon was so instead I want
to talk about some of the things that I
learned at VidCon for example that my
feet can hurt really bad for a really
long time before they stop working also
that if you're stressed up for two weeks
straight there will be some residual
stress even after there's nothing left
to be stressed out about and that kind
of stink also I learned that Michael
Buckley knows when you need a hug the
way that my dog knows when you have a
french fry and learn the jacket thin are
exactly as intelligent personable thawne
kind and attractive as you would expect
them to be I learned that creators on
the internet who seem really weird are
in fact pretty normal in real life aside
from wheezy waiter who is legit weird
I learned that extreme stress makes me
sleepy which is actually super
convenient
I learned that PBS is probably the most
innovative and successful legacy media
company in online video which it first
seems odd until you realize that PBS has
always focused not on content that gets
views but content that gets loved this
is actually given them a leg up because
in the world of infinite content and
free distribution the relationship
between the content and the viewer is
the only thing that matters I also
learned that pretty much every other
legacy media company out there has not
yet learned this lesson which I find
both frustrating and kind beautiful I
learned from Josh Sundquist that
concentrating on the 2% of stuff that
you can't do and ignoring the 98% of
stuff that you can do is idiotic I
learned from Zay Frank that I am a human
and I learned from Freddie Wong that you
can revive a dead youtuber if you get
enough people to sing to their corpse I
also really came to grips with the idea
that being active instead of reactive is
important to me at least what I mean
want to say that is that instead of
reacting to things that happen I think
about what my values are and what I
think should exist
and how things should be and act based
on that not based on external factors
but based on internal factors over the
last four years at VidCon we've had a
lot of people telling us to do various
things with the conference you know sell
it to a big media company or take
investment or you know do whatever the
sponsors tell us to do or grow to twenty
thousand people and saying no to those
ideas always always always has been the
best thing maybe not for the bottom line
of my wallet but you know for the
conference and also I think for my
happiness even like just starting VidCon
was an active move like no one was
telling me to do that I remember the day
I launched the conference staring at my
phone and panicking because like one
person had bought a ticket after three
hours and that was really really super
scary so thanks to Martha Stroud the
first person to ever buy a ticket to
VidCon she was there this year and had
some amazing things to say which I
really appreciate it she rocks we should
just give her a lifetime pass finally I
learned that I think though being out of
your depth is a really hard and
uncomfortable place to be it's probably
a good place to be it's kind of a cool
place to be as long as you have a lot of
support like I have a lot of support
from my wife and my parents and from an
amazing team who supports VidCon
volunteers creators and all of the
people who have either ever gone or ever
wanted to go to a VidCon I'm in your
decks thank you for supporting me even
though often times don't really know
what I'm doing god sorry you couldn't be
here at LeakyCon London pretty fun but
I'm glad you're back with the family and
I'll see you on Tuesday maybe I can get
some people to say hi hi John hi Oh
Johnny Oh Johnny hey Johnny John hi John
I miss you
John we miss you come here my dearest
John I wish you were here I love you